ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Today, we're talking
about Tau VMs, data ingestion,
and AppSheet in Gmail.
I'm Alicia, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
In June, we announced a
new virtual machine family,
Tau VMs, that extends
Compute Engine's VM offerings
with an option that
delivers the best price
performance among leading
clouds for scale-out workloads.
The first member of
the Tau VM family,
T2D, is now
available in preview.
This week, we're
excited to share
the results of
independent testing
by Phoronix, validating Google's
claims on price performance
leadership.
Check out the blog for more.
Developing cloud-based
data ingestion pipelines
that replicate data
from various sources
into your cloud
data warehouse can
be a massive undertaking
that requires
significant investment.
We have defined principles
for data pipeline planning
to begin the process.
These principles are intended
to help you answer key business
questions about your
effort and begin
to build data
pipelines that address
your business and
technical needs.
AppSheet's new
capabilities within Gmail
are powerful because AppSheet
is a true no-code platform
and anyone can create one,
making it easier than ever
to translate a great
idea into software
and deploy it to teammates in
an easily consumable fashion.
AppSheet apps can be
connected to the data source
of your choice, like a
Google Sheet, SQL database,
or Salesforce.
Imagine how useful
it'll be when creating
a dynamic email,
because you can update
data in any of these
sources without having
to leave your inbox.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.